agir maintenant c'est la recommandation
principale de la commission
paneuropéenne de la santé et du
développement durable aux gouvernements
et organisations internationales agir
pour éviter de nouvelles crises
sanitaires
trois objectifs sont ainsi mises en
lumière par la commission repenser les
grandes priorités politiques intensifier
les investissements dans les systèmes de
santé et d'aidé sociale et leurs
réformes
et enfin améliorer la gouvernance
mondiale des biens publics
nous appelons les chefs de gouvernement
et les organisations internationales à
réparer les fractures sociales et à ne
plus ignorer les conditions qui ont
permis au nouveau coronavirus
d'occasionner de si graves dommages au
niveau mondial nous avons le choix
ignorer les éléments de preuve et
risquer d'être encore plus durement
touchés par les futurs pandémique ou
tenir compte des avertissements et
appliqués les enseignements que nous
avons pu tirer car les conclusions de la
commission sont sans appel si ces trois
objectifs ne sont pas poursuivis
le monde ne pourra pas éviter d'autres
pandémies et les conséquences qui vont
avec
pour les membres de la commission la
pandémie de coronavirus a mis en lumière
la profondeur des inégalités et des
fractures de nos sociétés mais aussi
l'inadéquation de nos systèmes de santé
financiers économiques et sociaux le coc
vie 19 à jeter un éclairage violent sur
les inégalités qui existent dans nos
sociétés
l'accès à des services de santé de
qualité et la participation équitable à
la prise de décisions contribueront
largement à rétablir la confiance dans
les institutions à accroître la cohésion
sociale à stimuler la croissance
économique ainsi qu'à renforcer la
sécurité et à nourrir l'espoir la
couverture sanitaire universelle
constitue le fondement des sociétés
durables
cet appel à l'action de la commission
paneuropéenne arrive avec une série de
propositions la création au sein du g20
d'un conseil mondial
la santé l'amélioration de l'accès aux
services sociaux et de santé pour les
personnes défavorisées ou une nouvelle
conception des dépenses en matière de
santé ou de social comme je cite un
investissement dans le capital humain et
intellectuel moteur du progrès le
directeur de l' oms europe s'est
félicité de cet appel
la commission elle devrait publier en
septembre prochain un rapport sur la
façon dont les gouvernements peuvent
améliorer leur système de santé
du côté de la france par exemple en
matière de santé de 2013 à 2018 dit 7500
lits d'hôpitaux ont été fermés une
baisse de 4 2 % en cinq ans selon un
rapport de la direction de la recherche
des études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques
mais en tenant compte du développement
de l'hospitalisation partiel le nombre
de places a augmenté de 2,4 pour cent en
2018 que ce soit sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande ou d'emmanuel macron
l'objectif est le même le retour à
l'équilibré des comptes de la sécurité
sociale
un objectif qui semble donc en
contradiction avec les recommandations
de la commission paneuropéenne
reste à savoir si ces recommandations
seront prises en compte ou non par les
acteurs politiques
et si la tendance peut être inversée